you know recently i shared the
devastating news that full frontal
samantha b has been cancelled by tbs now
you might be asking questions like
why are you reading news from five years
ago or who the hell is samantha be but
if you're a fan of this show you might
not realize samantha and i have a little
bit of a history together
because my producers
obviously hate me as you know they
periodically make me watch feminist
comedians do their best imitation of a
suffering cat which of course i mean
they you know their stand-up comedy
routines is what they call them the very
first video in this try to laugh series
featured samantha bee you know we were
ahead of the curve we shot this back in
2020 let's just say that her jokes have
aged as well as a fine glass of milk
watch
so my producer suggested that i watch
and review some feminist comedy bits
and he he he suggested this because
evidently he hates my guts which is
understandable i i would hate me too if
i wasn't me i am me and i hate me so you
know
but uh the thing is i did actually watch
some feminist comedy in in anticipation
of doing this little youtube video and
uh but but much of it was so bad i'm a
feminist and usually like i'm um i'm
like not an advocate of like street
harassment and stuff like that um except
from
men that wear grey track suits
just so so
so bad i remember when kate middleton
announced her pregnancy
i was like i wonder if she'll keep it
who knows
that i thought maybe the fruit was
hanging a little too low a little too
little it's a little too easy and
there's all kinds of euphemism packed
into that last sentence that you can get
into later but then i thought if i'm
gonna review feminist comedy i shouldn't
go for the obscure ones i should focus
on a feminist comedian who is successful
well-known
allegedly talented and that's why i am
going to focus on samantha b you know
samantha b has her own comedy show on
lifetime or whatever it's on and she's
hailed by the media as brilliant and
hilarious and genius and so on that's
what the media says about her i figure
she's the best of the best when it comes
to woke female comedians so let me give
her a shot we're going to watch some
samantha bee
uh together and
more than reviewing it i think
i want to see if i can find a reason to
laugh
i want to laugh at a samantha bee joke i
want to see if i can do that today i'll
try my hardest
so let's watch this together let's start
with this we'll take a look okay
[Music]
meatpacking workers often contend with
cramped conditions grueling labor and
long hours so it's unsurprising that
plants have become hot spots for covet
19.
if we want to keep our food supply safe
we should first keep our workers safe so
naturally the president isn't following
aggressive lobbying from the meat
industry trump issued an executive order
aimed at reopening meat processing
plants look it's not shocking the
president leapt into action to save meat
because burgers
you endanger girl
okay um
so i think there are some jokes in there
i can't be sure
and this might be part of samantha bee's
genius that she tells she tells jokes
and and nobody knows that they're jokes
so she's deconstructing comedy that's
what i'm told that's the thing about
female comedians
samantha b hannah gatsby
they're always deconstructing comedy
rather than just
telling funny jokes and i don't mean to
imply that women aren't funny i would
never imply that i in fact in in stating
it explicitly
just kidding not really but sort of
okay let's keep going from ohio to new
york michigan to california
this morning the beef shortage at
wendy's is spreading the company with
that unforgettable catchphrase decades
ago is now having trouble finding the
beef you're out of beef then out of
patties it's embarrassing that the
where's the beef place is out of beef
it'd be like if someone at taco bell was
caught thinking inside the bun
okay
let's stop right there
this is a professional comedian folks
she makes millions of dollars
telling jokes
and yet she's never actually told one so
far as i can tell
so i'm starting to figure out that when
people say samantha b is funny which
i've never actually heard anyone say
that but theoretically
if they do say that they don't mean it
on the scale of comedians right they
they're using a different scale what
they mean is that she's funny
for a feminist
which is like saying like a corn dog is
healthy for carnival food it's just it's
so maybe if we understand it on that
scale we get into the mind of a feminist
maybe it becomes funny so let's uh
let's keep going
with some food shortages and increased
prices the federal supplemental
nutrition assistance program is more
necessary than ever about 38 million
people rely on snap benefits to feed
their families and last month the usda
announced it would increase overall
benefits 40 percent to give families
more money to buy food unfortunately
many food stamp households were left out
of the benefit expansion because they
were already receiving the maximum
amount now while democrats are trying to
raise benefits by 15 percent republicans
are attempting to block that change
just for context the maximum benefit for
a family of four is only
646 dollars per month for republicans
giving hungry families an extra hundred
bucks during a worldwide pandemic is too
big of an ask both because they deeply
passionately don't give about poor
people and because steve mnuchin needs
it to fashion sheets for his bed
my god
my god in heaven deliver me lord
let's try a different video maybe this
was this could have been a bad outing
you know it's it's uh that's fair like
not not not
it's not going to be great every single
time for a comedian i understand that
you know uh it's a tough job i have to
imagine so let's be fair we'll go to um
a different video we'll try this
um okay let's give this [ __ ] that's a
shot here still reporting from the woods
i had hoped that as we moved into spring
the forest would start to look green and
full of life instead it's totally
infested by gnats oh yeah they're
landing on my face now
stop there
kill
me
okay
given recent scotus wins it feels like
the pendulum may be swinging back to a
time when the nuclear family was
situated at the center of american life
where real conversation learning and
growth began at home with your family
gathered around the table
and president ronald reagan's farewell
address he said all great changes in
america begin around the dinner table
where you can bring your family to the
dinner table with good ranchers good
ranchers cares deeply about providing
families with high quality meat at a
reasonable price their mission is to
bring people to the table making those
shared moments with your loved ones easy
accessible and delicious good rancher
ships 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the u.s right to your door
plus when you subscribe your price is
locked in for the life of your
subscription good ranchers not only
supports american agriculture they also
are big fans of the daily wire they
support all of our shows which is
another reason to go check them out use
my code matt for 30 off plus free
shipping on your order take advantage of
this offer today you don't want to miss
it you can invest in time share it with
your family you're going to buy meat
anyway why not buy great meat from folks
who support all that we do here go to
goodranchers.com matt to start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious food
and given how afraid i am of the grocery
store that's how i'm getting half my
protein
as the great american lockdown continues
we have reason to be grateful social
distancing is working so naturally the
question on everyone's minds is when can
the country reopen unfortunately not yet
look i know it's hard i've been home so
long i got horny just thinking about
dining in at a pizza hut
okay um this is worse this is honestly
worse than i thought i'm actually i'm
plunging into despair right now i'm
losing my will to live every second that
i watch this i want to cry
i do i don't even know why i'm just i'm
overcome
by this wave of just total emotional
desolation that's how bad this is
it is making me long for the sweet
embrace of death i wish i was dead right
now i just had this image while i was
watching this i had this image in my
head of a guy burning to death in a
house fire
and i was jealous of that guy
because at least he's not watching
samantha bee
let's try um okay we're gonna abandon
this let's go
here's another video let's give this one
a shot third time's a charm right that's
the same goes here we go i don't know
about you but for me it's crucial to
stay productive during quarantine for
example at the start of the year i
bought a journal to keep tabs on every
book i've read and every film i've seen
but now i'm just keeping a list of every
porn i've watched that's troubled me
starting with hardcore kissing it's not
what you think you know what maybe okay
maybe she's having a hard time with
coronavirus material because it's let's
be fair it could be hard to come up with
funny jokes around the chronicler so
let's we'll go back we'll go back a few
months just to be fair
let's find a video of of her from before
all this so this is from last july and
uh we'll give this one a shot let's take
a look in the past week our beloved
president of the united states of
rhodesia has done so many racisms we
don't have time to cover them all so if
you want to hear about trump's social
media summit his threatened ice raids
and his failed effort to weaponize the
census turn to tbs 2 for full frontal
after dark where i rant in my sleep
about what a prick our president is then
stay tuned for old sheldon but for now
let's focus on the
did you get
this because
there's a there's a show called young
sheldon
and so she's saying
there's a show called old what if
there's a show called it's not young
sheldon it's old sheldon
that's a joke let's focus on the three
racist things trump's been up to lately
starting with this president trump
unapologetic defending his racist
twitter tirade aimed at four democratic
congresswomen of color after telling
them sunday to go back to help fix the
totally broken and crime infested places
from which they came sadly the only
thing that should surprise anyone is
that he wrote from which they came to
avoid ending a sentence with a
preposition way to go shakespeare now
return your head to the orifice from
which it came
of course it wasn't long before i'm
trying
this
this is
this is not a bit at this point i want
to laugh at a samantha bee joke i do
that is on my bucket list
some people want to
climb mount everest i i want to find i
want to find a funny samantha b joke
that's all i want to do with my life now
i want to be able to say out loud that's
why i want to be able to say this
have you heard that hilarious samantha b
joke
and then i want the person i'm talking
to to say did you say hilarious samantha
b joke
and then i go yes you sexist
what you don't think women are funny
well listen to this and then i'll repeat
the joke and we'll all have a good laugh
that's what i want and and it will end
sexism once and for all
that is my goal it's the only thing i
want to do with my life now is my life's
work i will find the joke uh let's keep
looking we'll go to a new
video um
here we go i'm feeling good about this
okay this is a this is a greta thunberg
related thing so there could be some
good comedy here let's take a look to
most of america i'm samantha bee the
comedian samantha be the style icon
samantha'll be the author of the 12th
most popular line of self-published
dinosaur erotica on amazon canada but at
home i'm just mom for my own parenting
experience i can tell you there's
nothing more terrifying than a teenage
girl and right now one teenage girl in
particular is scaring the crap out of
all of us
what's your message to world leaders
today my message is that we'll be
watching you
and she means it too this morning i woke
up and she was standing over my bed
that of course is greta tunberg the 16
year old swedish climate activist who's
been traveling the world with one simple
message she's just a girl standing in
front of a group of world leaders asking
them to do something before the whole
planet melts and we all die you all come
to us young people for hope
how dare you for more than 30 years the
science has been crystal clear
how dare you continue to look away
and come here saying that you're doing
enough
when the politics and solutions needed
are still nowhere in sight the only
thing scarier than a 16 year old girl is
a 16 year old girl with an agenda who
knows how to hold a grudge
greta toomberg
terrifies me and i love her for it
okay
samantha kind of ruined it there but
when she started trying to tell jokes
but i did
i you know i
i did crack a smile at the greta
thunberg clip is it tuneburg time
i've been saying thuneberg this whole
time i'm going with thunenberg
that one gets me that clip gets me every
time i have to i'm sorry it does it's a
little it's a little funny
um so we might have to count that as my
samantha belaff i might just have to
call it and say that that that qualifies
but let's see we'll we'll we'll we'll
plunge forward one more time
let's give this a shot
she doesn't want to inspire us or give
us hope she wants to give us nightmares
because we deserve them greta is
bringing something very important to the
discourse about climate change shame
she's traveled all over the world
ripping into our craven leaders like a
miniature don rickles in braids and you
know what it is working her
international shaming tour has led the
eu to commit hundreds of billions of
euros to combating climate change she
got the british parliament to declare a
climate emergency and pledged to zero
out its carbon emissions by 2050 and she
got the banned scorpions to finally stop
rocking everyone like a hurricane
hurricanes are dangerous uh
no that we're you know what we're just
gonna i'm i'm gonna call it i can't do
this anymore that's there's only so much
punishment a man can take this is like
this is like someone gave a microphone
and a laugh track to my drunk aunt at
thanksgiving and i just i can't do it so
the greta thunderberg thing that counts
that's my laugh i did it i'm done
uh goodbye
[Music]